this is a production of Cornell
University there are micro toxins there
[Music]
ear rot in corn and this here right
produces monsen's so we're interested in
so they're more common and they're
linked to a variety of problems human
heal cancer childhood stunting and also
they're a big issue in livestock
especially the FDA regulates this range
2 to 4 parts per million for dates
probably referencing the two parts to
William limit mostly and so here you can
see here right and these white streets
on the kernels he one is we comment a
toxic of johnson's this is a paranoia
that were sort of working the other
today is the idea that Kucera here
colonizes the kernels and causes the
kernels that colonizes to be less dense
and if you decrease density we think
that will be linked to an increase so
one way to mitigate commonness is and
they're sorting there's all sorts of
sorting methods such as size based
sorting such as screening out finds
which can be more toxic and also
spectral based sorting methods such as a
Miraflores to detect sexual
characteristics why do we want to sort
well a breeder
I want a low-cost you know typing
alternatives
farmer might want to increase the value
of the crop and then
so in our lab we can look at this
cartoon of how it actually functions
drop your unsorted maze drops one by one
a less dense kernel will be in your
reject bin where there's less terminals
which are typically more toxic or as
denser kernels are like more likely to
say so when especially efficiency
[Music]
specificity being the rate of true
negatives how are you doing it keeping
your good kernels and your sensitivity
your rate of true positives how are you
doing at rejecting the benefits so to
calibrate this release we see 3d printed
plastic maze it's worth what started by
June shed speed a former masters student
in their lab and so on the top row we
had each color corresponding to a
different density we also sizes small
medium large and different shapes such
as vs. and they won't you all these
results but it can in fact
we have and we three times we have the
different fractions and I should point
out that if we're thinking of this as
trying to meet some legal limit it works
really are accepted fractions still have
the majority sniffles exceeding that so
I want to zoom in further to understand
at the single kernel level what's where
traits also single kernel traits that
could be related to monson and so it 72
accepted kernels and send me to rejected
kernels from one sample and measure the
mass which is very simple just by
placing it on a scale
more difficult it's complicated to
measure keep in Stuart in my first lab
we helped a small device that takes 36
pictures and then usually code from a
German group which is valued carving to
make a 3d reconstruction of the kernel
it's also interested in the visual
appearance and so I scored these kernels
based on their symptoms
finally material so now he's showing me
some histograms of each single kernel
characteristic and in single kernel
masks we have a significant decrease or
the dashed lines are V means of each so
I rejected fraction mean was
significantly lower than except the
fraction in terms of mass everyone
there's a lot of overlap between the two
similar volume there is a significant
decrease in the rejected fraction the
rejected fraction kernels tended to be
smaller however however when you just
divide by volume to find density we
found no significant difference between
the density of the kernels each fraction
hustling based on the theory other
shorter however on that the distribution
is here much narrower than they were
from massive volume making it more
difficulty for a sorter to separate
other when we look at actually monastic
in our single set the transform values
which is a good thing and I also want to
point out higher than this to parts per
million
we're most concentrated in rejected
fraction and here we see it has some
false negatives median so I know if you
look at how each of these traits
correlated to log transformed function
and so if you directly attention to the
right hand column you see that for each
characteristic there was significant
only slightly negative correlations with
dress party monson indicating that
single kernels with higher few monofin
ended to be lighter smaller and less
dense and I finally wanted to look at
based on the single kernel data set how
well we were doing with the sorting
predict accepted was our accept bid and
we found that negative 90 I mean when
we're starting we're getting a lot of
positives I wanted to compare this to
how just we do it so based on that
visual scoring right classifying one to
two visual score as except period for
visual stories we had similar
effectiveness comparing our machine to
sew and iris does indicate that visual
characteristics of the maids is
important for all that being said I'm
working to integrate
these tools with other sorting methods
such as visual here I'm also interested
in using these tools on ear rot
resistant slow sight and thinking of
ways to use the drops or to enrich
samples of toxic overhauls and using
various tools to measure single Pro
attributes so this has been a production
of Cornell University on the web at
cornell edu